人家一看你没有背景，
一看你娘家也给不了任何的嫁妆，
一看你工作能力又不行，
一看你身体又不好，
现在大家都很现实，
谁都想过好一点的，
轻松一点的日子，
谁都不想被别人拖累。
我是95年的，
今年31岁了，
我对象是九一年的，
35岁，
我的工作不太稳定，
做过开奖，
然后也做过直播带货，
20年之前的话有个7~8000，
现在的话就特别卷了，
后降到了5~6000，
工作一直在私企，
也不是特别稳定，
还经常换工作，
我对象的话，
他也是做主播直播带货的，
他当场的话是按小时付费，
一个小时100，
他之前最高的时候有一个小时挣过1000的，
也是做直播带货啊，
前几年一个月有个2万，
然后这两年也是不行了，
现在他就是要找三份工，
就是去三个公司打三份工，
三个直播带货才能挣个一万八九，
一天差不多要工作12个小时，
再加上来回的车费车程啊，
那些差不多十五六个小时都在路上，
我是原生家庭，
是不太好，
没有助力，
我爸爸就是之前是在外面摆摊啊，
我是重组家庭，
我是北方人，
在我18岁之后，
他们俩离婚了，
然后我妈妈又嫁到了四川，
我跟我叔叔之后他们就没有再生孩子了，
我叔叔妹妹是有两个女儿，
我这边的话我是独生女，
只只有我跟我妈妈，
我来四川也有个大九年了，
那么肯定是稳定在四川了，
不会去。
跟我北方的那个爸爸有任何的联系了，
包括我18岁从那个河北出来之后，
就从来没有跟我爸有过任何的联系，
这也不太理解他为什么有我的某些我的手机号，
却从来也不跟我联系，
我妈妈的话呢，
他也从来没有工作过，
所以说也没有任何的退休金啊，
那些补贴，
我叔叔的话是有个园林，
可能每年政府要补贴个点钱，
但是也不是特别多，
我对象的父母的话，
他们是摆摊儿的，
做炒饭，
一个月有个两三万，
一年要个20多万，
然后他家的话是有一个姐姐，
她姐姐是已经结婚很多年了，
孩子也很大了，
还有一点就是我的身体太好，
就经常就是这里不舒服那里不舒服的，
经常就头疼，
失眠，
腰疼，
反正一个月七八天能睡好就不错了，
犯了很多的大夫医生，
中医西医都在看的，
身体特别差，
他的话就是身体特别好，
每天的话他能睡四个小时，
就能播12个小时，
我现在想问的两个点，
很纠结的两个点，
我们俩谈了一年了，
他的这个情感是非常淡漠的，
张铁直男，
所以他连我的身体不舒服都不知道呀，
我都疼的拉肚子拉了三天了，
就是我第一反应是啊，
那就不行了，
吃药已经解决不了了，
那就应该去医院了，
然后他就来了一句，
身体有这么不舒服吗？
还要去医院，
我从来都没有去过医院，
就是他没有这个意识，
包括我经常跟他说什么头疼脑热，
这里头那里头，
我就喊着他去给我买药，
他第一反应就是多喝点热水，
睡一觉就。
好了，
结果我们俩这一年的磨合，
反正他慢慢的也知道了，
原来人还可以，
这里不舒服那里不舒服，
就是他从来没有生过病。
还有第二个点就是他的负债，
前几年的话是做生意亏了，
然后亏了个50多万，
说这些年他父母陆陆续续的帮他还了一些，
然后他自己也在还，
现在还有16万的负债没还。
房子的话是前两年是买了的，
但是在五环外就相当于有点郊区了，
因为我们在市区工作有点远，
所以那个房子准备给他父母住，
车的话是买了的，
30多万的车是买了的，
车贷已经付完了，
房贷也付完了，
那父母现在就是准备再给我们在市区再买一个房子。
目前纠结的就是这两个点，
就很崩溃的点，
谈个对象吧，
就没钱也没爱，
一年甚至两年才能还爱吧，
他这个也给不了你太多，
他虽然说他也在积极的去改变，
可能他性格上就是这样，
就很难去改变，
然后我又年龄上很焦虑，
我觉得我都31岁了，
我觉得如果我现在22岁，
我再等他个3~5年，
我都完全没有问题的，
可以重新开始再找一个吧，
我有没有这个勇气从头再来，
我也不知道该怎么办，
想听听你们的意见，
姐妹啊，
这么说啊，
生你的亲生父亲都不怎么关心你，
都没有任何的嘘寒问暖，
不要寄希望于任何一个男人会无条件的关心我，
无条件的爱我，
尤其是当我自己如果身体也不好，
赚钱也不行，
娘家也不。
给力，
没有任何资源可以拿来置换的时候，
不要上来就寄希望于别人无条件的爱我，
关心我，
降低期待。
不管你今天跟这个男的好，
还是以后换个男的过，
都是要降低期待的。
不要希望连生我的养我的有血缘关系的爸爸都对我没有什么关心，
我上来就寄希望于一个男的关心我爱我，
为我付出，
扯淡。
如果我是你，
我身体也不好，
我赚钱也不行，
我娘家也不给力，
那我就看使用价值。
我跟谁在一起的时候，
我能住上我觉得比较舒坦的房子，
我能开比较舒坦的车，
我能挣的钱够我去看病，
够我去吃，
我就跟谁在一起，
我就看使用价值。
我不期待别人关心我，
我知道我没有什么可置换的，
我唯一能置换的不就是尽在陪伴价值了。
而且我告诉你啊，
久病床前都无孝子，
如果我身体一直不好，
我一直这疼那疼，
这失眠那不好，
那你不要寄希望于任何一个人可以一直关心我，
我知道我这个话说出来零度的话啊，
非常让人寒心，
但事实就这样，
就算是你自己生的，
你自己养的，
你到年老的时候，
你身体不好，
你今天这疼明天那疼，
今天上医院挂水，
明天上医院要住一夜，
照样对你没有多大的耐心。
经历过的扣1，
我说的是不是现实，
所以当我自己身体不好的时候，
不要想着别人会关心我，
我就是看我跟谁在一起的时候能有实用价值，
能让我腾出更多的时间精力对我自己好，
能让我腾出更多的间精力我自己去照顾我的。
身体看病而一切，
如果你跟这个男的在一起，
假设房子他给你提供了，
车子他给你提供了，
基本的生活开支，
他支持了，
那你赚的钱是不是就可以照顾自己的身体了？
你不要寄希望于他带你去医院，
不要寄续让他给你买药，
让你吃药，
提醒你不要，
我自己会带着我去医院，
我自己会给我买药，
我自己会查我得了什么病，
我该怎么治，
见没有啊，
今天我讲这个话，
就算你现在听着觉得不顺耳啊，
觉得不舒服，
但是我讲这个话就是现实，
我要寄希望于别人，
任何人来关心我，
为我负出干嘛的，
就是我要关心我自己，
我要对我自己的身体负责。
我发烧了，
赶紧查一下，
赶紧去医院，
我拉肚子了，
我要是睡不着觉了，
赶紧去看看心理科这些，
凡事都要靠自己下地起丐，
我懂了，
你就看跟他在一起你能有什么房子，
有住的吗？
有车子，
有开的吗？
有生活费他出了吗？
出了好我挣的钱就顾好我自己，
不要期待，
他会关心我，
他会爱我，
他会对我的人生负责任，
真的就是还是要继续在一起嘛，
因为他爸妈一年能挣20万，
他也一年能挣差不多20万，
他们家庭收入一年40万比你强多了，
他使用价值是我这个年龄呢，
其实也不容易能够找得到更合适的事情，
人家一看你没有背景，
一看你娘家也给不了任何的嫁妆，
一看你工作能力又不行，
一看你身体又不好，
谁，
我跟你说，
现在大家都很现实，
谁都想过好一点的，
轻松一点的日子，
谁都不想。
拖累，
突然觉得以前看那个恋爱电视剧看多了，
没有白茫茫，
我来拯救你，
只有我自己，
不要寄希望于任何人来拯救我，
只有我自己明白了还是要靠自己，
自己长的，
别人都看得起你，
自己立不起来。
其实没有任何人会想到你对姑娘，
这其实在你人生当中，
可能18岁20岁就应该学会的这一刻，
你现在才开始学会对，
我就觉得我很晚熟，
我怎么到现在才忍白回到你自己看我跟他在一起有没有实用价值，
有实用价值的话，
我都该感谢他能给我房子住，
我该感谢他能给我车开，
我该感谢他，
生活上她支出了成本，
我该感谢他。
好，
就这样啊。
这里没有贬低的意思，
我就客观陈述一下，
对于那些娘家不给力的，
娘家拖后腿的，
自己工作能力不是很强的，
身体又不是很好的，
这样的女孩子来说的话，
刚才这个故事就是你们的解药，
刚才这个心态就是你们的解药，
你们的心态就一定要调整，
调整成不图谁爱我关心我，
我只图跟谁在一起的时候，
我能腾出手来爱我自己，
关心我自己。
刚刚有的人是不是单身更好？
妈呀，
自己工作能力又不行，
挣那点钱，
你除了吃饭租房子，
哪够我的去吃药啊，
看病啊，
你找人就是得找实用价值的啊，
有地儿住挺好，
有车开挺好，
记得点赞关注哦。